we've been fed the idea of how a
relationship should look like but there
are people who that's not the
relationship they need she was on the
Forbes 30 under 30. she is the CEO and
co-creator of an incredibly Progressive
dating app please welcome to the show
Anna karova I was really excited to talk
to you why are we so uncomfortable with
challenging the blueprint of what a
relationship should look like in a world
where we challenge every other blueprint
of how everything else should look like
our extreme discomfort and fear of
discussing anything relating to
sexuality is causing this inability for
people to be able to connect in a more
authentic way if there's anything that
is constant in the world it is a change
and to me relationships are generally
moving in this direction of people
seeking to grow together applying a
growth mindset to themselves and to
their relationships and exploring
feelings that don't feel comfortable
cushy and safe is a part of that growth
thank you